[Musique]
combien 2 une poule pond tel par jour ça
dépend le plus souvent c'est un mais ça
peut aussi être zéro ou même
exceptionnellement 2 sans surprise la
pente peu varie beaucoup selon la saison
l'alimentation et la race certaines
poules de fantasy ne pondent que 100
tonnes par année tandis que les races
utilisés dans les élevages industriels
où une production annuelle de 300 5e
l'équivalent de 25 douzaine une poule
pond 1 neuf toutes les 24 à 26 eur
environ elle se repose 30 minutes avant
de relancer la production en plus de ces
pauses l'épaule prennent une petite
journée de congé de temps à autre mais
attention même si une poule pondeuse
peut vivre jusqu'à 7 ou 8 ans elle ne
peut pas maintenir ce rythme de ponte
toute sa vie les meilleurs productrice
vont pondre plus de 300 e la première
année mais ensuite la pompe diminue
après deux ans elle baisse de 40% et
s'effondre par la suite voilà pourquoi
la très grande majorité des producteurs
de ne gardent leur poule qu'un an et
pour ceux qui se demandent en règle
générale les poules blanche d'homme ou
tes yeux blancs et les poules brune des
cheveux bruns par contre pour savoir qui
de l'oeuf ou de la poule est arrivé en
premier cela fera l'objet d'une
prochaine capsule